the Israeli military says it surrounded
Gaza City after approaching from
multiple directions the least 23 of its
soldiers have been killed in battles
with Palestinian Fighters since Tuesday
Israeli troops have moved in from three
positions in the north and in the East
there's been heavy fighting Northwest of
Gaza City as Israeli forces move towards
at tatra towards the Alara neighborhood
battles have also been reported in jar
ADC and to the north of that area
Israeli forces have also been seen on
the main salahadin road which links the
north of the strip to the South the
Israeli Army and the Navy have been
targeting vehicles on the AL Rashid
Coastal Highway this means Israel Now
controls access to and from the main
road connecting northern and southern
Gaza Alex bad begins our
coverage the jabalia refugee camp under
bombardment for the third day in a row
this time near a un run School turn
shelter for ordinary
[Music]
Palestinians the Abu Hussein school was
a refuge for thousands who had already
lost their homes in the Israeli
bombardment the repeated attacks on
jabalia have left hundreds dead and the
UN Human Rights office says that could
amount to a war
crime major strikes have also hurt the B
refugee
camp and in southern Gaza another
journalist killed in an Israeli strike
Muhammad Abu hatab was a correspondent
for Palestine TV dead as well as 10
members of his
family his death was announced on the
channel he worked for his colleagues
saying there's no point in wearing
protective gear because journalists are
being killed
regardless and as the bombardments
continue from the air on the ground
Israel says its troops have now
completely surrounded Gaza
City
Israeli forces have completed the
encirclement of Gaza City the center of
the Hamas terrorist organization in the
last hours artillery and infantry forces
in cooperation with the Air Force have
been attacking bases headquarters
concentration points and other Terror
infrastructure used by Hamas and its
terrorists but the armed wing of Hamas
says its Fighters continue to
resist we are fighting on our land
fighting in its sky soil air and water
we will make Gaza as it was the curse of
history for this
[Music]
entity Israel has ruled out any
ceasefire saying that would amount to a
surrender and as its troops press ahead
with their offensive Palestinian
civilians spend yet another day
searching through Rubble for their loved
ones and burying the
dead Alex beard Al
jazer we can speak now to Al jaz's Han
Mahmud he is in Unice inside the Gaza
Strip so according to the Israeli Army
it surrounded Gaza City what have you
observed in terms of the ground
offensive what is the latest in the
north all
right well since the announcement of a
deep push into uh the Gaza City coming
from the North and the East the entire
area become has has become a closed
military zone and and it's a war zone
for real as of uh there extreme battles
and fighting going on between uh Israeli
military tanks and Palestinian uh
militancy group under heavy uh
bombardment air strikes and mass
bombardment Israeli are moving slowly
what seems to be a push uh to uh the
center of Gaza where the Israeli
military said it's the center uh and the
headquarter of ham leadership where all
the controlling and planning uh going on
to do so Israel not only isolated the
northern part of Gaza uh from the South
but it's working now on isolating Gaza
City completely as coming from the
northern side and the Eastern side
cutting two main roads leading and
connecting Gaza City with the central
part of Gaza and the southern uh part
now there are reports talk about the
fierce fighting going on as as tanks
keep pushing into Gaza reports about uh
mines and and Bobby traps and ambushes
and in to do to encounter these on the
way to Gaza Israeli military resort to
using a lethal for Air Force by
destroying more residential buildings
and entire uh residential blocks turning
them into ruins uh to cut uh supplies to
uh Palestinian uh militant group the
situation is is a war zone for Real uh
but unfortunately with thousand of
people are still stranded in Gaza and
the northern part uh their expectation
that the number of casualties and the
number of of those are being killed is
going to uh rise up by the coming uh
hours as these people have no safe place
to go after the announcement that GA the
entire Gaza City and northern part uh be
has become a closed military zone give
us a a bit more detail on how many
people and how many children ordinary
Palestinians not Fighters that are still
trapped inside this active war zone and
as you've been reporting have now no way
of moving to the South and escaping that
fighting we just doing a little bit of
simple math the number of civilians uh
in Gaza and the northern part including
children uh men and women and elderly
outnumbered the number of of uh of is
what Israeli reports talk about
militants inside the Gaza uh uh City and
the northern part the vast majority the
vast majority of people who are stranded
there are civilians the shifa hospital
alone uh has about 40,000 evacuees came
from all uh the areas uh just to uh take
the hospital uh as as a shelter have no
way to go now uh with the short extreme
shortage of of basic supplies and food
and access to water and basic uh
survival items life is becoming
extremely difficult uh for those people
as no one is able to leave there the
past two days when a Rashid Road the
coastal Road was announced as a passage
for people to take to go to the southern
part uh there multiple cars civilian
cars ambulance Vehicles a un car that
were uh targeted on the road there are
some 25 uh Dead uh bodies now on the
road with multiple cars uh completely
burned as a result of the air strikes
and the naval uh bombardment again uh it
it looks like uh a it's a war on
civilians a war on on on the people who
decided not to to leave uh Gaza and the
northern part yesterday there were
leaflet it dropped by Israeli plane
ordering people in shter refugee camp to
leave but because people had nowhere to
go they decided to stay there if despite
the the sharp warning in the leaflet uh
it's not safe the road that they're
talking about is not safe there are cars
that are getting bombed on that road
okay thank you so much for that update
honey mahm there for us in KH unun in
the south of the strip